in 2016 Clint Bolick became an associate
justice on the Arizona State Supreme
Court making him one of the most
influential libertarians in today's
legal world that appointment is merely
the most recent career highlight for the
61 year old activist author and policy
wonk in 1991 bollock and chip Miller
co-founded the Institute for justice the
country's premier libertarian public
interest law firm in 2007 he became vice
president for litigation at the
Goldwater Institute Arizona's leading
free-market think-tank where he took on
restrictive licensing zoning and
business regulations and became a
nemesis to Joe Arpaio the
self-proclaimed toughest sheriff in
America i sat down with Bullock in
Phoenix to talk about his legal
philosophy the politics of immigration
and why he sports a tattoo on his
Taiping finger but I started out by
asking him to discuss one of the most
interesting cases to come before the
High Court during his tenure which
involved warrantless GPS searches this
case involved putting a tracking device
on a truck and basically the police were
following it for several days before
they finally stopped it and of course
made a drug arrest we ruled four to
three that a warrant was required I
voted in the majority on that and then
we voted five to two that the good faith
exception to the exclusionary rule
applied to allow the warrantless search
in that case I joined the Chief Justice
and dissenting from that why do you
think a warrant is necessary for police
to do this the warrant requirement is
really the last protection between
between an individual's rights and and
tyranny they're easier to get than ever
before you can get one in a matter of
minutes if it's justified and I think
that our framers by putting this in the
Bill of Rights really believed that
before someone's individual rights their
privacy is violated in most instances
you ought to get a warrant how did
people or why did your fellow justices
rule this was you know
covered by an exclusionary exception we
had to interpret federal Supreme Court
law that is mystifying for example we
are asked by the US Supreme Court to
determine whether the privacy interest
involved is one that society is prepared
to accept that comes from a decision
from in the middle of the last century
how's a judge supposed to know what
society is - is prepared to accept and
what if that changes tomorrow it really
was a matter of seven justices trying a
good faith to figure out Supreme Court
law we've got to talk about that tattoo
can you hold this up sure you're the
only inked member as far as you know of
the Supreme Court that's right that's a
tattoo of a scorpion yes why do why do
you have that on your face so one thing
about public interest lawyers and I know
anyone who's done those kinds of cases
will identify with this you really get
into the cases and I at the Goldwater
Institute I took on the cause of a
tattoo artist who had a very successful
studio in Mesa and wanted to open one in
the college town of Tempe Arizona
invested twenty five thousand dollars
and this was during the recession in a
an abandoned store in a strip mall
obtained a use permit from the city of
Tempe and started his business lo and
behold the neighbors decide they'd much
rather have a Starbucks of course
Starbucks was not planning to come there
so they went to the City Council which
actually repealed the use permit and
suddenly these folks were saddled with
with this lease and and a lot of lost
investment I read about this on a
Saturday afternoon called the tattoo
owners and I said would you like to
fight this in court and they said we
can't afford a lawyer and I said what I
always love to say is a public interest
lawyer we're free along the way and this
case went all the way up to the Arizona
Supreme Court years before I was
on it I said you know what if we win I'm
gonna get inked and sure enough we did
win and I did get inked and I have typed
everything I've ever written every
reason article every book every brief
with one finger I don't even use two so
I decided that I would get a tattoo on
my typing finger and that it would be a
scorpion which is a little desert
creature with a powerful sting in terms
of judicial philosophy you've described
yourself as a textualist
what does that mean and how does that
match up with say an originalist or a
you know other kind of legal theory
so textualism i think is is a branch of
originalism but what textualism does is
to rely on the meaning of the terms of
the Constitution or a statute to the
maximum possible extent and often if
there are old words then we look at what
the meaning of those words were at the
time they were adopted using
dictionaries and other sources and then
to apply the principles that those words
represent to contemporary reality so an
originalist who is not necessarily a
textualist tries to find original intent
and I think that that is much more
subjective because you can often find
people on different sides just to give
you an example the gun rights cases that
went to the US Supreme Court were very
originalist in their orientation and you
had very strong arguments on both sides
of that to be but a textualist will
follow the words and another thing about
a textualist
is that every word is given meaning so
for example we have no ink blots and the
Constitution as as Robert Bork was
famous for saying to give you a tangible
example of the difference between a
textualist and originalist an
originalist might have decided Brown
versus
Board of Education differently because
an originalist would have looked back at
the time of the 14th amendment and found
that lawful segregation was ubiquitous
and therefore how could the framers have
intended for the Equal Protection Clause
to outlaw segregation a textualist will
look at the Equal Protection Clause and
say well it means what it says and
whatever the framers of that amendment
meant by it or whatever they did that
might have contradicted that principle
you apply that principle of equal
protection Arizona is one of the state's
most enmeshed in political and cultural
debates about immigration in 2014
bollock and former Florida Governor Jeb
Bush co-authored immigration wars which
argued for a complete overhaul of
existing laws in a way that is both pro
immigrant and pro economic growth one
thing that a lot of people do not
realize is that alone among
industrialized nations on the earth our
immigration system since the 1960s has
been primarily a family based
immigration system not an economics
based system the definition of family
has expanded so dramatically that it's
really the driving force behind most
immigration if we were designing a
system from scratch I don't think it
would be that way we would want we would
want high-skilled workers we would want
workers to fill jobs at the lower ends
of the economic goodness but would we
also only see immigration as a function
of needs of the economy real or presumed
or would it also be that individuals who
don't necessarily have a relative here
you know that they have a shot of coming
that's absolutely right and one of the
many aspects that we took on in the book
we both passionately believed in
immigration we are truly a nation of
immigrants and one of the things that's
disappeared over the years so many of
the opponents of immigration today argue
why don't these people just get in line
and one of the things we pointed out and
this is perhaps the most important point
that we made in the book there is no
line if you do not fit into
one of the handful of visa categories if
you are not a relative of someone living
here the only line is what's called a
diversity lottery which hundreds of
thousands of people apply for every year
your odds of getting it are virtually
zero if there was a line for people to
get into they wouldn't necessarily have
to break the law to come here so how do
you feel about on the one hand there are
a number of Republicans particularly in
the Senate who have who are pushing
legislation that would almost have or
cut in half legal immigration and you
know and then they said we're gonna of
course secure the border so there'll be
no more illegal immigration will be half
as much legal immigration but then also
Donald Trump recently has started
talking about skills-based immigration
and that we he's done such wonders in
the economy that now we need more
workers than ever where do you where do
you see the immigration debate playing
out well it's it's an issue where there
is a tremendous amount of consensus
among ordinary people and almost none in
the political parties it's so
frustrating but the idea of having our
immigration Milton Friedman once
famously said that you can't have a
welfare state and have open borders the
flipside is probably also true you can't
have a welfare state and not enough
people to support it our population is
is ultimately in decline we just don't
have young people we either have to
import people or we have to export jobs
and right now we are actually exporting
more jobs than we're importing people so
we cannot find ourselves in a situation
where we're reducing legal immigration
Trump of course as a businessman has
thrived from immigration and every now
and then you see indications that he
understands the policy are there enough
Republicans and Democrats who could make
common cause you know eliminating family
based immigration was something that the
so-called gang of eight agreed to or
reducing it I should
and there are commonalities
I think legalizing all of the daca
individuals would be another part of
that compromise solution what I think we
can get there and if Richard Nixon could
open up China so potentially could
Donald Trump open up immigration one of
the great nemec's in your career
particularly in its Arizona phase was
Sheriff Joe Arpaio what do you think was
driving him in terms of immigration and
I mean he ultimately ran afoul of you
know various court orders to stop doing
what he was doing regarding you know
harassing immigrants you know what
drives somebody like you know I have
never been a very good amateur
psychologist I know that Sheriff Joe
loved the limelight and certainly
immigration brought him into the
limelight if you look at his early years
he was the furthest thing from a
militant on immigration issues
quite the contrary he said we should not
prioritize tiny little crimes just
because immigrants are committing them
and then in fact he a lot of people
don't remember he endorsed Democrat
Janet Napolitano for governor but then
he made a really hard turn and I I
really am at a tremendous loss to
explain it but it came to the point
where it was a diversion of resources
from much worse crimes that were being
committed and you know he he was found
to have violated a number of federal
immigration laws you guys stole exchange
Christmas cards you know it's funny he
is one of the most charismatic guys you
could meet and whenever we do see each
other he could not be a more pleasant
person although well now that you're on
the Supreme Court he knows he's gonna be
in front it is funny the day I took
office we happened to be at the Capitol
together for the governors State of the
State and there was a a line for food
that he was in and I was
off to the side and he walked by me and
he does a double take and he says
anything that happened before today is
history where many libertarians are
content with going after the federal
government Bullock has long warned
against what he calls grassroots tyranny
in a 1993 book of that title Bullock
argued that petty local bureaucrats were
often quicker to stomp on individual
rights than DC lawmakers this is
something that had occurred to the
framers if you read the Federalist
Papers Madison was very concerned that
the smaller the government the easier it
is for special interest groups or
factions as he called them then to gain
control and to execute what he referred
to as their schemes of oppression and I
think that we do see that we're
especially low turnout elections I and
special interest groups that that really
dominate a lot of local governments they
do engage in behavior that violates
other people's rights so I think that
really those books were a clarion call
we focus on the national government all
the time and we we often ignore the
threats in our own backyard who has more
control over your day-to-day lives your
City Council or the President of the
United States it's your City Council
it's your school board so it's it really
the solution is to be kind of limited
government or libertarian all the way
down or to push for that oh absolutely
and to get to get engaged you know just
as it's easy for for the bad guys take
to control local government so is it
easy for the good guys to be very
influential at the local got at the
local level and and I rarely see that
that kind of activism how do you when
you think about the Institute for
justice which a lot of the cases were at
the local or the state level things like
occupational licensing zoning
restrictions weird you know attempts to
screw people over you know at a lower
level of government when you look back
on that now
how do you you know how do you how do
you feel about the influence that the
Institute for justice is that I don't
think when when chip and I came up with
this idea in his backyard in Denver what
if if we had sat there and said what are
your wildest dreams about this whatever
we would have said I J has exceeded
those wildest dreams we started with a
staff of seven after our first three
years one of our donors described us as
the best law firm that's never won a
case and it it took a while to gain
traction and now you know IJ is one of
the most significant legal organizations
in the country
winning US Supreme Court cases on a on a
regular basis I couldn't be more proud
yeah and also I mean just injecting a
set of ideas into public yesin even in
the cases they lose
yeah and that's right the key locates
being at the preeminent example do you
think Arizona is becoming more free and
when you step outside of Arizona is it
becoming more free in terms of economic
freedom cultural freedom civil liberties
alright I mean are we are we headed in
the right direction or are weak treading
water or we going back you know it's
really hard to say on the one hand the
threats to freedom of speech are are I
think worse than at any time in my
lifetime and we just don't see people
value freedom of speech as as much as as
we once did what what do you think
explains that I just you know I think
that we are dividing more than ever
before into warring camps and it's an
ends justifies the means kind of
philosophy I teach constitutional law as
an adjunct professor at ASU and the
first day of class I say I want you to
develop a set of neutral principles that
you will apply in all circumstances if
if people did that I think we'd be much
better off but that's not happening
today and that's really really
disturbing on the flip side you do see
some real progress for economic Liberty
both the left and the right seem to
value
entrepreneurship small businesses
Arizona
recently became the first state to adopt
an economic liberty act that I designed
many many years ago but it was until I
was on the court that it was adopted and
it flips the presumption instead of a
plaintiff who challenges a barrier to
enterprise bearing the burden of showing
that there's no rational basis the
government now has the burden of showing
the rational basis how do you feel about
civil liberties you know however you
want to construe that do you think we're
you know is the is the government being
forced to be more respectful of people's
rights or you know is that something
that's always kind of a no-man's land
battle that's just yeah going back it
really it really is the pendulum swings
back and forth and I you know like that
the GPS case that I mentioned you know
all so many of those cases are four to
three and again even at the grassroots
level you have people totally willing to
violate other people's civil liberties
and insisting that their own be be
recognized this is where I think that
libertarians can play a very very
significant role and that is to show
that if your free speech rights are
violated my free speech rights are
violated if your due process rights are
violated so our mind that we have a
universality when it comes to the
protection of Rights and frankly there's
no one else in the society right now
that I think has neutral principles that
they will apply in all all instances do
you enjoy being a Supreme Court justice
I absolutely love it you know I loved
being a litigator but at this stage of
my career I have lots of people I've
trained and mentored over the years who
are doing the litigation stuff and I
love bringing my experience to bear and
working with six other people who are
extraordinarily bright extraordinarily
well meaning to reach in many instances
a collegial decision
you